With pressure to get to COVID shots in 221, what is available supplement to
powder spike proteins as I feel these have progressed my cancer?
Yeah, you know, I've been careful not to, you know, get harmed too much the COVID
vaccines because we have a number of people that have gotten COVID vaccines. I think
this is my opinion. I think there's a horrible mistake. COVID vaccines are not
vaccines whatsoever. There are RNA tools to damage your body period and you don't
have to be a conspiracy theorist to see what has taken place in our society with
this huge spike in cancer and cardiac issues. And if you are denial of that,
you're denial of reality. So I'm glad you're open to this. But some of the things
that you could do to help a person is, first of all, you for the clot
formation, I highly recommended product called lumbrosine. These two products
here are both US enzymes products. Nanozyme is the other one. So lumbrosine and
nanosine are two good products that are enzymes that will help break down the
clot formation that could take place that could cause cardiac issues. Another good product
is ala scented. I think that's how you spell it. That's a premier research garlic. But
you can get garlic. You're really anywhere. You can get garlic on with a counter, which
is good. Don't buy any other lumbro kinase product because that's what lumbrosine is,
lumbro kinase. Don't buy any other nano kinase product, except these US enzymes products.
These are the absolute cleanest purest lumbro kinase and nano kinase. Literally, nothing
else touches it. This is PRL's garlic, which is a blood thinner. So if you're out of blood
thinner, you have to be careful of that. Take too much of this. But really any garlic,
any over the counter garlic, even that garlic brand, they're still good products.
This is going to help with the spike proteins, but this will help with the effects of the spike
proteins on the red blood cells and the anothelial cells that is causing the clot formation. As far as
getting rid of the spike proteins themselves, there's nothing that's been proven to do that.
However, looking at keylating agents, like the Benilex Citergy,
is a good product that we have. It's one of my favorite products as far as a keylating in such,
so that we privately labeled it as our phase zero, oops phase zero assist.
This is just got some really, it's got such a nice blend of keylators that you think of
what that's what you want to do is try to grab on to the spike proteins and pull them out of our
body. So that's what I would use is this. You know, if you're using Pectusol C, that could be
beneficial. We have key look clear. That's beneficial. The Benilex Citergy is just got a bigger blend
of keylators in it. Make sure that you're not constipated. Doing coffee animals are nothing but
helpful. And a reason why coffee animals are so helpful is because they help stimulate your
parasympathetics. That is going to help you get rid of this stuff. Parasympathetic nervous system
is your neurological control over your immune system and the neurological control over your detoxification
pathways. So these are the kind of things that I would suggest. If I had the vaccine,
I would be probably taking two of these at about three times per day. So the same thing with the
nanosine and the same thing with the garlic and the same thing with the Benilex Citergy really have to
you know, flood your body with that.